[Music]
did you guys hear about kim kardashian's
40th
birthday party and she's celebrated on a
private island she's so [ __ ] hot
that's all i got to say man she really
is so pretty
the more i learn about her the more i
[ __ ] love her guys me too i'm wearing
skims right now i'm addicted you are
i ordered new skins yes i ordered new
skins that's a skin
let me fill this [ __ ] it's the skims
this one's the do they have it for men
but there's other material that skins
below your mind yeah look at her this is
her i just thought it was 40.
i mean give me a [ __ ] break right
she's so cute and she's so
short she's like a little pint-sized
cutie the more dollars you have
it reduces your aging i heard that is
true and it makes your boobies and your
butt bigger
that's for sure and your lace little so
she tweeted this out where is it this
one
she's like 40 and feeling so humbled and
blessed there is not a single day that i
take for granted especially during these
times when
we're my husband's created that truly
matter
she put some photos another one says
after two weeks of multiple health
screens and asking everyone to
quarantine i surprised my closest inner
circle with a trip to a private island
where we could pretend
things were normal just for a brief
moment in time that's dope
yeah and people are so mad about it
though because of covet stuff she's like
we dance
rode bikes swim near wales kayaked
watched a movie on the beach and so much
more
i realized that for most people this is
something that is so far
out of reach right now so in moments
like these i
am humbly reminded of how privileged my
life is hashtag justice
is twitter like you gave the whales
covered you pieces of [ __ ] everyone
somehow like how dare you
don't post about it's like who [ __ ]
cares is that what they're mad about
yes okay so i know just from comments
people are getting
some woman wrote a comment that was like
wow maybe you should be home
like getting your husband the help he
needs it's like first of all how can you
you're not responsible for another one
getting mental health and you know she's
definitely tried
why does kanye need help he's perfect
20 20. i voted for him you didn't vote i
haven't voted yet i'm still thinking
about it um
i'm still thinking about whether i'm
going to vote no about whether or not
but um but then so there was that
response where i'm like why that's so
crazy to like put that on her
she's like running an empire she has 47
kids
she has tried to help him from what i've
seen and also it's like none of your
business
just to like shame a person and she's
like turn 40. she wants to have a nice
well it's her fault it's her fault that
kanye went crazy it's her fault that she
turned 40. yeah
and it's her fault that she's rich and
she worked really hard
it's such a weird it's her fault that
she got [ __ ]
and got famous from it i know that's her
mom's you know her mommy was buying that
one
but do you feel like i don't know why
things are still going off in here
but do you feel like um dude
sorry did you see the david letterman
interview with her yes i saw clips of it
could she not love her more
that's what i'm talking about because we
saw the interview when you see her
because listen i'm from a bar want to be
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] she's making people
want to get
fake body parts and stuff like that like
this isn't like healthy or whatever and
she's at this or that and then you
listen her she's just like this really
like
smart driven i'm like normal person
she's just very very normal
very human [ __ ] they're rich like and
when she was about the oj thing like
they were
how traumatizing is that that your
family was like so close with this
family
they had been on vacation with nicole
brown simpson and oj and the kids and
a week later that happened like that is
like a lot she was young she had a bowl
cut just like you but she has the time
she has the tom brady problem right
where she's hot as [ __ ]
she's successful as [ __ ] she wins at
everything she does and so everyone's
like [ __ ] you because
how hot do you think tom brady tom
brady's hot as [ __ ] dude
43 years old he's hotter than you how
old is he how old is he he's 43.43 yeah
but i got all of those trades
and no one hates me you just get hotter
and hotter dad i [ __ ] hate
but yeah that's exactly it though like
that was the response from the public
everyone was just like
like kim how tone deaf are you like
there's people dying
oh [ __ ] off peasant [ __ ] they were
posting that meme
of when they were at some tropical
island from
the keeping up with the kardashians tv
show when she lost the diamond earring
in the beach and then courtney's
like in the villa and she's like holding
her kid and she's like kim there's
people that are dying
like they kept posting at me but who are
we gonna talk [ __ ] about if it's not her
right we can't lose all these people to
talk [ __ ] about we got reality stars
they're so used to having everyone on
them at all times it's like
who care like that's why she even had to
preface it the way she did like i know
that my life
is pretty like it's foreign she should
have rubbed it in even further like my
life is
so awesome you will never even have a
minute of my experience
and i know that so i am so humbly
privileged i wish she was sitting like
in front of a giant [ __ ] chocolate
sundae or something yeah
she's like me while everyone's tweeting
at me
sorry about your grandparents
quote tweeting it i forgot who it was
but someone ended up quote tweeting it
uh her tweets with let him eat cake let
him yeah
just mind your business honestly what if
we do the opposite i was calling hinks
there's a page
that just puts up a normal person a day
and everyone goes
in on that normal person every single
[ __ ] day that'll be tired so then
everyone can experience what it's like
to be uh
on social media a regular person [ __ ]
johnny lee or whatever you put them on
and everyone goes
in on this [ __ ] okay johnny lee
everybody go get them like the reddit
roast me the the subreddit so
the other thing that people are really
upset about though is the fact that it's
like okay fine
you're rich you can afford it good for
you but do you really have to rub it in
everyone's faces she's not rubbing it in
you stupid [ __ ] peasants
also unfollow her you follow her you
like see
i didn't even know this existed until i
was presented you know you know what it
is it's people that
feel there's there's so like there's the
two trains of thought right like the
victims of kovid like obviously people
are dying covert is 100 real
it's scary my dad and mom have not left
their house they've gone on little walks
they're fully messed my dad's like
wearing goggles right because i don't
know if it's so smart
but i love it i'm like so grateful for
that because if my parents were like
going to the mall or something i'd be
like
so scared for them and then there's
people that are like this isn't real
and they always end up getting covered
and then they die they literally always
get covered the worse than everyone else
but it's like it's up to you how you
choose to like
to put yourself out there and they're
not no one's on that island with them
they went to an eye and they're doing it
i always feel like the mask argument
where people are like i don't want to
wear my mask it's like
it's my right but it's like your mask is
to protect
other people around you by the way that
was my chair did you hear the fart sound
i didn't know i was not doing it i
literally was like i wouldn't have been
able if i farted i would have been able
to continue through the sentence but now
i feel guilty i would have called you
out for it your facebook
yeah i didn't do that like oh my god did
i notice yeah but there's no one on the
island with them if they were like
partying in miami right now i'd be like
oh that's a little weird
you're like out where people could be
there i think the biggest thing is if
you hate her so much
unfollow her it's not just that because
the media takes every little thing that
the kardashians do and make like
big things they make them more rich yeah
i think it's human nature though
to misdirect your anger all the time
anyway it's not about
how people are concerned about covet or
whatever they see a target and then they
just go out
oh my god i went on a private jet and i
didn't
think of the people you're so tiny but
you're gonna love this because i
made it i knew it was gonna be like a
thing
so i didn't say where i was going or
what i was doing but the story's so not
cool
it's like the least cool thing it was
like you went to a fake airplane
no it wasn't a fake airplane it was i
met two pilots
who they have to every two weeks if they
haven't taken the plane out they have to
just check and make sure the plane's
doing well oh yeah yeah so they
they go up i literally i took off and
landed nothing else happened
like i didn't even see burbank [ __ ]
like i was like up and down
and and i posted like a video and
everyone was like and i was wearing an
american flag shirt like
perfect i should have known what was
gonna happen you can't wear american
flag
and i was nunchucking because i've not
joked so i was like on the plane i was
like oh my god no
i was like when you fly private you can
bring weapons it's so fun you know and
everyone's just like
you privileged and it was like if you
guys knew the story
behind this it's so nothing wow and then
i like this guy was fight i just i went
in with a guy which i shouldn't do but
every once in a while you take the
adderall you look at the thing you start
responding but this guy was like this is
white privilege and you're so privileged
and all this stuff and i was like by the
way
so white i'm like i can only be like
racially shamed by people of color i
cannot have a white person
try to tell me that about my privilege
like he was a white guy telling the
white
and like you assume i'm voting for trump
because i'm wearing an american flag
like you psych
like do you know anything about me like
follow one more post
and um you ever reply you're just
jealous of my white privilege you're
just jealous
i'm white i'm whiter than you oh my god
that's the funniest thing
i want to see a white white battle
you have too much too much sun or
whatever but he so we're he's going on
and i go
dude honestly i don't to have to tell
you this like because i i don't have to
justify this but
i was like but i just have friends that
are i met a pilot like i'm friends with
everybody goes
oh see there's your privilege knowing a
pilot he doesn't own the plane
you can't win you could be a pilot too
you have to go to school for it yeah
like i know flight attendant exactly
it's may is when he could have been a
flight attendant yeah
yeah i know yeah i know a person that
works
at an accounting firm i know a singer
yeah it's so crazy they're just jobs and
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you talking about
i'm a chatty [ __ ] i know a lot of
people
but it was so funny and then make
friends you lonely [ __ ] it's so crazy
it's social privilege is what it is
you're social if you feel like you
you don't want to leave right i always
feel like because i'm so i'm wild i'm
outspoken
and people they get annoyed with me and
i realize what it is
is like proper women that are polite and
have followed all the rules
[ __ ] hate me because they're like we
did everything right
and we sat here and we like minded our
business and we were like sweet and
you're crazy barreling through
getting like attention and having a fun
life like what the [ __ ]
they're haters yeah they're like well i
you should have to have like
sat there quietly the whole time like
sorry
i went to a juvenile delinquent school
i'm combed hair how would i i was hoping
that was a real one
that's so dark no i mean like not
because you i want to see you stab
yourself
toys and i have so many weapons someone
just gave me a someone gave me a pretend
like a practice
uh butterfly knife i'm so excited oh
yeah
do you know how to do it because no i
just got it i was just trying to
you have it no i wish i had my nunchucks
too i usually bring them with me
so does joe yeah oh i have wooden ones
too
mine had um bruce lee on them okay but
they grabbed me i hit my own head with
it so i stopped these are hard to get
yeah no i i'm not good at it i hurt
myself every time
[Music]
this is a demo guys i'm not good at this
don't hit your head
don't don't don't hit your head no
people are and then people will critique
how you nunchuck i'm like yeah i'm not
good at it
oh yeah for sure you should be holding
with your index why are you stupid
[ __ ] you're white privileged
my white privilege is that i don't know
how to use nunchucks
anyway back to kim here so a lot of
people started using her
little caption i forgot it was about kim
kardashian
where they went they started naming it
so this is like a scene from parasite
and it's captioned with after two weeks
of multiple health screens and asking
everyone to quarantine i surprised my
closest inner circle with the trip to a
private island where we could pretend
things were normal
for just a brief moment in time that's
so funny it was like parasite
this is mid-summer this is people have
too much damn time
the scooby-doo yeah they memed it so
that's funny it's just
and then like oh that's funny fire fast
that's pretty funny nothing was better
than fire fest
yeah that was really good and then like
this other tweet says thinking about the
mass server in the background of this
second photo
who is likely among many who risk their
lives so that kim kardashian can have a
birthday party the choice of worms
they probably made so much money they
probably are so happy
yeah but then he looks afraid for his
life back there dude
like he's like [ __ ] yes i'm getting that
sweet uh that sweet risk pay dude
for sure and then the last one here is
in defense it says
if i could afford to fly my friends and
family to a private
island right now i would and i bet you
all would too yes you have a great
mother the waiter is asleep in his house
gunmen come in and like you're working
this [ __ ] party
no please i just want to be safe from
kovid and like you're walking this
[ __ ] body you cock's like a piece of
[ __ ]
it's so absurd i do want to know like
everyone that was there though
yeah that was what annoyed me i was like
i was zooming in the background
there's not enough people yeah i know
what's the price yeah because then if
they are calling them shitty then we're
mad
she spent about a million yeah you're
probably getting
thousands they're like hello thank you a
million is nothing to them how crazy is
that so yeah they're [ __ ]
billionaires independently that's what
everyone's talking [ __ ]
i have like a bunch of rich friends and
i always have to ask them i go is this a
lot of money to you is this a lie
what was an amount that you asked like i
asked well joe rogan just got that deal
with spotify
yes and i was like does a million is a
million it goes a million still a
million to me
because he used to pull out like because
i was always like i live in my car and
that's like your 13th car like what's
going on
and he would like just laugh at me and
like pull out a wad of hundreds and be
like
this means nothing to me and just hand
me like 300 bucks i'm like oh my god
i love this joke i love this joke i read
for months i was like oh my god
but isn't it [ __ ] up he was showing
off in front of you yeah what it did how
can i i was like
how dare you have joy and laugh at the
fact that someone has more money than
another person
ah he's so tone deaf so i don't like him
oh my god it was sad when he stopped
doing the jokes i was like remember that
joke
i told that joke one more time can you
do an hour of that joke please
every time he like puts me on a show or
something i'm like i'm getting really
close to being able to pay you that 300
back i'm getting
really close that's [ __ ]
[Music]
hilarious
[Music]
you